[Música]
Imagine si pudiese conectar su cerebro a
una máquina que le brindase el máximo
placer el resto de su vida se apuntaría
Esa es la pregunta del filósofo Robert y
su experimento mental que llamó la
máquina de las experiencias el
experimento nos pide pensar en un mundo
donde los científicos desarrollaron una
máquina que estimula la vida real y
asegura experiencias placenteras en las
que no hay dolor El único problema es
que debería dejar atrás la realidad pero
casi sin notar la diferencia no podrá
distinguir las experiencias de la
realidad los altibajos naturales de la
vida serán reemplazados por una
secuencia infinita de momentos positivos
suena muy bien verdad puede parecer una
oferta tentadora Pero puede que no sea
tan buena
de hecho el experimento se creó para
refutar una idea filosófica llamada
hedonismo según los hedonistas maximizar
el placer es lo más importante en la
vida Porque el placer es el bien más
grande que la vida tiene para ofrecer
para los hedonistas la mejor opción que
Cualquiera podría elegir para sí mismo
es la que le trae el máximo placer
posible sin producir dolor el placer
ilimitado sin dolor es igual al máximo
placer o en otras palabras lo que ofrece
la máquina de las experiencias
Así que si usted es hedonista conectarse
a la máquina sería la opción obvia Pero
y si la vida no se resumiera solo al
placer es lo que no se creyó demostrar
con su experimento mental la máquina de
las experiencias Aunque la máquina
promete máximo disfrute él decidió no
conectarse lo mismo que otros al
presentarse la propuesta
Pero qué nos puede disuadir de elegir un
futuro lleno de placer Imagine la
siguiente situación Betsy Sander están
comprometidos en una relación amorosa
Betsy está totalmente enamorada y nunca
se había sentido tan feliz pero sin que
ella lo sepa Sander ha cortejado a su
hermano Angélica a través de cartas de
amor y visitas secretas durante la
relación
se enterara se destruirían sus
relaciones con sunder y con Angélica y
la experiencia sería tan traumática que
no volvería a amar de nuevo ya que Betsy
es feliz sin conocer las infidelidades
de Sander los hedonistas dirían que es
mejor no saberlo y mantener su alto
nivel de placer
mientras Betsy no descubra la traición
su vida seguramente continuará tan feliz
como ahora
entonces tiene algún valor que Betsy
Sepa la verdad Imagine que usted es
Betsy preferiría saber la verdad si la
respuesta es Sí estaría eligiendo algo
que reduce drásticamente los valores de
placer Por lo cual tal vez crea que hay
cosas en la vida con un valor Más alto
que la mera satisfacción la verdad el
conocimiento relaciones auténticas Todas
estas son cosas que pueden incluirse En
esa lista sin saber nunca la verdad
Betsy básicamente vive dentro de su
propia máquina de las experiencias en un
mundo de felicidad que no tiene base en
la realidad este triángulo amoroso es un
ejemplo extremo pero refleja muchas de
las decisiones que tomamos a diario así
que si toma una decisión por Betsy o
para usted mismo por qué creería que la
realidad se debe considerar hay un valor
intrínseco en las experiencias reales
sean placenteras o dolorosas
tiene usted más valor cuando experimenta
los placeres y dolores de la vida real
el experimento de nausei Puede que no
ofrezca todas las respuestas pero nos
obliga a reflexionar sobre la vida real
que aunque imperfecta tiene un valor
intrínseco Más allá del estado de placer
infinito
profundice sus reflexiones existenciales
con esta pregunta Cuál es la diferencia
entre la realidad y nuestra
interpretación de ella contemple Este
infame experimento de pensamiento con
este video